6 26 on your wednesday morning a
frustrated viewer email has earned us
all a free trip
to traffic 101.
viewer deborah writes i moved here two
years ago still can't believe the number
of drivers who have no clue what to do
at four-way stops seriously there should
be a public service announcement between
them and the speeders i'm lucky to get
home with no car damage
well deborah here are a couple of quotes
from our friends at the nevada
department of motor vehicles
at a four-way stop the driver reaching
the intersection first gets to go first
after stopping completely
also at a four-way stop wait for other
vehicles already in the intersection
allow vehicles that reach the
intersection before you to go first wait
your turn
and just in case you might be new to
driving world we'll go ahead and say it
if two or more drivers show up at a
four-way at the same time
well the person furthest to the right
gets to go first ever thanks for writing
in maybe this could be considered your
public service announcement buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone something's driving you crazy
email me traffic eight eight news now
dot com